as I know only too well
perseverance pays and these richly
talented ladies nominated tonight are
none of them overnight successes no sir
they are all seasoned perennials who
have been acting since there were
teenagers and I strongly suspect that
they will continue to do so until they
are even older than me
and an in this year of remarkably brave
performances I am somewhat dismayed to
have to announce a winner but I look
forward to the honor of working with any
of these ladies in my next 30 films
here are the nominees for Best
Performance by an actress in a
supporting role Amy Adams the master
Valleyfield
Lincoln and Hathaway Raina
Helen punt your sessions
Jackie wheeler silver linings playbook
and the Oscar goes to Miss Anne Hathaway
walk away
grateful getting married
it came true oh thank you so much to the
Academy for this and for nominating me
with Helen Hunt Jacki Weaver Amy Adams
and Sally Field I look up to you all so
much and it's it's just been such an
honor thank you I there are so many
people whose generosity and support is
the reason that I'm standing here right
now I must thank Hugh Jackman Hugh
you're the best the cast the crew
especially Simon Hays in the sound
wizards congratulations on tonight you
guys the creative team behind Lima zurab
Cameron Mackintosh Tom Hooper from
working title Eric Felner Tim Bevan
Deborah Hayward and from from Universal
Ron Meyer Donna Langley and Adam
fogulson thank you guys for your faith
and thank you for this opportunity I
have to thank my team led by the
lion-hearted susan by Mel
Josh Lieberman Nick Sullivan Mahad Akil
please say I just said everyone Josh
Lieberman again just to be safe
Stephen who vain Jason Sloan and special
contributions by Frank Sivaji and Carrie
Wagner I want to thank my friends
especially the ones who are cheering
from Crosby Street tonight my family who
I'm so blessed to be a part of my
husband by far and away the greatest
moment of my life was the one when you
walked into it I love you so much
and thank you for this here is hoping
that someday in the not too distant
future the misfortunes of Fantine will
only be found in stories and Nevermore
in real life thank you